un élément important de l'enquète sur le
meurtre du petit grégory aurait-il été
gâchée à la justice si l'on en croit
deux journalistes du républicain lorrain
oui cet élément c'est un témoignage dont
on ignore pour l'instant si les
capitales en tout cas rien n'a été fait
pour vérifier l'importance de ce
témoignage patrice pollet légendes ainsi
un artiste décorateur qui partage sa vie
entre paris les vosges où il a de la
famille au rêve le jour du crime vers
17h30 une voiture cachée sur un petit
chemin creux menant à la vologne
à l'époque son témoignage communiqué à
la police parisienne bien que transmis à
nancy n'auraient jamais été versées au
dossier du juge lambert alors chargé de
l'enquète quatre jours plus tard c'est à
dire le 20 octobre jean d'aci alors
qu'il repasse à moto au même endroit or
est intervenu de nouveau la même voiture
avec quatre personnes à bord elle
démarre à toute allure légende assise
précise que le jour de l'enterrement
il aurait reconnu la télévision deux de
ces quatre personnes
le juge simon qui dirige maintenant
l'instruction du dossier sur l' affaire
grégory a confirmé hier qu'il entend
vieux monsieur jean da si après
l'ouverture d'un supplément
d'information dans cette affaire